the jurogan experience well do you want
me to tell you about the ayahuasca
experience
sure do you remember how much do you
remember
well you know i i remember
uh how i found out about it which was
weird because it was a friend of mine's
wife but i'd heard that ayahuasca word
before and
so i knew a very very little bit about
it so then i started kind of researching
it
what is it where does it come from it's
a strong hallucinogen you know which
i've always had a tendency to like
anyway so i thought it sounded like it
was right up my alley but
for a long time you had to get on a
canoe you know and go down and find a
corrugated tin shack and sleep on a dead
floor
and
and so it wasn't very appealing to a lot
of people so
the guy that opened the place
uh he had money and he said he bought
part of a
like a jw marriott beach resort where he
bought their overflow area which was not
on the beach but in the jungle with a
big fence [ __ ] howler monkeys the
most useless animal in the world they
scream at the top of their lungs other
monkeys
must just hate them you know can you
tone it down a little bit
how how how
so i thought well i'm signing up for
that and i'll use that to get off liquor
because a lot of people do come away
from there with a different perspective
right which i did
and uh but then they i was honest with
them about how much i drank and they go
oh no
you can't come here
uh you we don't want you coming here and
getting into dts that's not we're not a
detox facility and we're not set up for
it
so you have to have 14 days of sobriety
before you come here and i'm like [ __ ]
right i don't know if i could do that or
not because i was drinking so much and
uh
and then i knew about this guy there was
a hypnotist in uh
marina del rey i think is kind of where
uh that's not it it's uh
whatever one of the coastal towns down
there
and my assistant anthony
had a uh worked for a guy that had a lot
of problems and went to this guy and
quit all of them and uh so i'm like well
i could go over there and see how that
works
so i went over there
and uh
his office was in his garage he was the
least impressive human being i've ever
met and they had a brown wig that was on
crooked and i don't know if that was
part of it
that you get focused on dude what's up
with your wig and
and that maybe got you off beat a little
bit and uh and then he had a tall glass
of water with no ice in it and he took
these little tiny sips out of it now i
don't know if that was part of the setup
or not
but the garage thing was like a velour
recliner that had been 30 years old it
wasn't well kept or anything and so i
sat in there and uh and then he just
talked about
you know kind of what was going on with
my body and all this liquor that i was
pouring into it and kind of like how
your heart and your lungs and your
kidney like to work together to keep you
living and i've had an all out assault
on all three of them for 50 years and
and
you know whatever
and uh
and so he got through with the first
session and he would put me under and i
would go under that's for sure and
because he'd have to snap me out of it i
was just sitting there conscious of
everything he was saying
but in a whatever hypnotic state for
sure so he was good at that and uh
and obviously it was kind of weird
because he said
imagine you're on the 22nd floor of a
building and you're getting on the
elevator and it's kind of weird because
i live on the 22nd floor of a building
he didn't know that
but odd
and uh so i finished the first session
he says okay don't don't quit drinking
i'm like great great i'm i like this
program so i came back and i thought
maybe i it was four sessions over a
period of a month
and
and so but after the second one i quit
drinking and uh
and i was just waiting for the shoe to
fall you know i was waiting to start
getting sick off not drinking and uh and
it and it didn't happen and it really
didn't bother me not to drink and it was
set up for as soon as i was finished
with that i'd go straight to to south uh
or uh whatever uh
whatever that pill i took uh
costa rica and uh and i checked into
this place and it was really really nice
you can go you can where you can share a
room with somebody which they recommend
that experience with somebody you don't
know
but i don't want to do that so you can
also get your own room and it's not
overly expensive compared to rehab in
malibu you know which i repriced at 100
grand
uh for 30 days what 100 grand uh really
three grand a night and they recommended
a minimum of 30 days and uh and that was
on the street i lived on in beverly
hills up at the top of it
and uh
so this is like
you could do this for like if you shared
a room with somebody for like like 1800
bucks for a week and mine was like five
grand but i had a nice room and it was
you know really nice place they cooked
all your food
and it was healthy
but it was really good you know it was
uh no soda pops no alcohol no you know
uh
a lot of [ __ ] i wouldn't advertise if i
was trying to get people to go down
there and uh but you know pineapple
juice and coconut water [ __ ] great
and uh
so
the you get down there and you had a
group of about 50 people i think was in
our group that were and uh they
everybody has their own room but then
there's this one space where everybody
gets together for this experience of
ayahuasca so there's
50 mattresses on the floor that have you
know really nice sheets and pillows and
blankets and they're on the floor and
it's very ceremonial in that you know
there's a guy a shaman that looks like a
shaman
feathers and [ __ ] and uh you stand in
line with your little cup and
he gives you a cup of this mud
awful taste and stuff
and i did mine in it i just talked to
him like his regular person
and uh i said so what do you do and he
says well outside there was a bunch of
hammocks it was beautiful space really
couldn't have been any better and the
hammocks all around just go out there
and sit in a hammock and whenever you
need to when it's time you just come
back in i said how do i know when it's
time he goes oh you'll know
okay all right so i took my ayahuasca
and went out there and i'm like oh it's
kind of like mushrooms a little bit i
felt myself coming on to it
and then uh and then i opened my mouth
and the entire forest poured into it and
i'm like that's probably the signal
right there that it's time to go in i
think i get it so i went in and i laid
down on my
my bunk
now some people throw up on it so you
have a puke bucket too but some people
get the shits
i got the shits vomiting's way better
because you can vomit from your bed but
if you got the [ __ ] you got to get up
and find some place there's bathrooms a
lot of them so but i never thought i'd
see people throwing up in a bucket and
go lucky
dude i wish i was throwing up but i got
the shits and so i laid down and i
tripped
so hard and it was really dark and they
said
lean towards the dark side so if there's
a
a rainbow and a unicorn and then there's
a guy you don't understand in your yard
go that go towards the dark guy in the
yard don't hop on the unicorn and jump
over the rainbow go the other way
and and don't fight it just let it
happen but i think i just struggled with
it the first night
and uh and
and i i was getting really distorted
images of people's faces when they got
close to me and
and i was tripping so hard that it was
like my head was itching and i just
couldn't figure it out you know how to
make my head stop itching
and uh i thought about scratching it but
i wasn't exactly sure how to use my
hands anymore and somebody walked by and
i asked them to scratch my head and
they're like yeah sure like this
yeah oh that's it that's it that's good
and
i really thought
towards the end of that
that i wouldn't do it again
because i just didn't see the benefit of
of it you know it scared me it didn't
scare me
but it wasn't pleasant at all you know
like it wasn't like mushrooms and it
wasn't like acid uh
to me it wasn't and uh and you could
almost see somebody's skull when they
were too close to you and it was
i was just wanting it to be over
and uh and the beautiful thing about
ayahuasca is it is over
i mean it only goes for like two hours
and when it when it's done it's done and
so they time it so you can do more you
could do all you want but but not past a
certain point and then it's at one point
they turn on the lights and go good
morning and it's over
you know you can't just go home go back
to your room and go to sleep real fast
but
it's over
all those things are gone it gets out of
your system completely so fast
and then there's you know there's music
there's a you know live band or you know
people in congo's and guitars and [ __ ]
so it was funky and some people were
even while i was in my wildest point of
this trip
they were up just dancing around the
room i'm like
jesus christ how are you doing this i
don't understand
and uh so i thought and i think that's
about enough right
and then uh the next by the next
day once i got out of it and then people
kind of sit around and share their
experiences and whatever
and i was into the whole thing and i was
really trying to surrender myself to the
experience you know i was trying to do
what they were asking me to do and uh
and get the whole ride you know and uh
so the next night i went in and he gave
me it was a different shaman every night
and uh
the
he gave me about a half a cup
and uh i said the other person gave me a
whole cup of this and he said
yeah the mother ayahuasca
said to give you the night off and
and tone it down for you and he i don't
know if you talk to the other guy and i
don't know why i said that but
so i took that dose and i went outside
and
i sat for and i noticed it had been a
while a while and it and it started
coming on to me and uh and and i just
felt this overpouring of love
i mean it was just amazing
uh
for everything i felt it just filling my
body with just love and and happiness
and so that night i was really just
digging on the music got up and danced
uh everybody wears white and i thought i
didn't know why at first but that's so
they can't see you s they can see you
sneaking off to your room to get some
smokes
because they they busted me doing that
the first night i was like
trying to creep away i'm like i didn't
know you could smoke out here but uh
so
the uh
that was great
and uh
afterwards uh
i really felt a just deep connection to
the whole place you know
it felt like this was you know a journey
that was you know designed for me you
know because i just felt
wonderful about myself about decisions i
was making
uh about the direction i was headed in
my life and all this stuff and then
the next night was a bigger dose and i
went back and got a bigger dose and went
back and got another dose
and just wrote it out and [ __ ] loved
it and uh it was really just that first
and he said that the first night was
kind of a death and the second night was
a kind of a rebirth
and uh i'm like okay
whatever so the last night you started
at like
seven i think and it's over at 12 30
uh
the that experience and then the last
night
you start at five and it goes till 10
o'clock the next day
so you do smaller doses but you do them
all night long
and uh
and and that was really groovy for me
but this one chick
completely wigged out and uh and i mean
kicking
screaming and yelling really unpleasant
and uh they had to take her outside and
tie her up before she hurt somebody
and i thought
why aren't these guys wigging out over
this because i am you know
because it looked like she was going to
hurt somebody or hurt herself and they
were having a hard time controlling her
and she didn't even know that it was an
ayahuasca place she thought it was a
yoga place and her husband signed her up
for it now she had done ayahuasca three
other nights and was fine but this time
she she just [ __ ] lost it and uh so
they took her outside and they just
bound her up and they stayed with her
and but
here's the thing when it's over
it's over
and even though everybody was really
concerned about her she came back in
with the biggest smile on her face
and she had some demons
and she needed to work through it and it
was horrible i know what it was
that happened to her
because
they told me and uh and it was awful
awful awful so some stuff from her past
some stuff from her past uh horrible i'm
saying yeah and uh
so
so she went from
who knows what in what place she was in
to the biggest smile
i've ever seen
and she worked through whatever it was
and uh
so
and then i met some friends down there
they got married the next morning we'd
been up all night and you know some
ceremony thing but i was just into it
you know
and then uh genie my girlfriend came out
and then i was gonna stay for two weeks
and i decided not to so i'm gonna go
back another week and do it again
i don't know i haven't decided my
schedule's so packed now i can't even
find a spot for it and uh
and then i'm going to do stand-up for
one more year and then i'm going to
retire watch the entire episode for free
only on spotify